what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our own mega level and Beyond
Omega level series we are going to cover
Rick Sanchez we're gonna cover pickle
Rick so this is like the seventh time
that I've tried to record this and
actually this video is extra long
because this first part is me doing it
seriously and then the second part is
the video where I couldn't stop laughing
so it's uh you guys get the best of both
worlds undoubtedly there will be people
who will be like I did not subscribe to
see videos about pickle Rick I've never
laughed once in my life chill out you
got next week until the end of all time
to get serious
Omega Beyond Omega level videos anyway
if you are not familiar with pickle Rick
he is a version of Rick Sanchez from the
animated series rick and morty that airs
on Cartoon Network's Adult Swim and also
has produced its own comic book series
from Oni Press and while Rick in his
standard form boasts an impressive list
of feats pickle Rick simply takes him to
another level if it helps to think about
this encounter book terms think of Rick
Sanchez as the baseline version of The
Incredible Hulk and pickle Rick as world
breaker Hulk without being said if we're
going to understand the immense power
that is pickle Rick we first have to lay
some groundwork and explain who Rick
Sanchez is and what he's capable of so
Rick Sanchez is the smartest man on
earth and I am not exaggerating here
he's literally the smartest man on earth
as a scientist with superhuman intellect
Rick has invented numerous things that
are far beyond what was previously
thought humanly possible his most
notable invention is his portal gun
which as the name implies allows him to
create portals to any point in space in
time in any universe which means that
Rick can travel throughout the
multiverse at will Rick's other
inventions include a gun that shoots
antimatter that can destroy some of the
strongest beings in any dimension a
watch that shoots a particle beam
capable of disintegrating matter on a
subatomic level and dream in scepters
which allow him to enter the dreams of
any other person and implant new
thoughts into their minds so at his base
level Rick can pretty much invent
whatever he needs to allow him to
complete whatever task in front of him
he can travel through space he can
travel through time and he can even
allow dogs to communicate with humans
via a special helmet that he created and
how could that possibly go wrong right
so I think the best way to help you
understand pitbull Rick is to begin by
quickly going over his origin
and then discussing the feats that we've
seen him perform what we need to keep in
mind though is that we've only ever seen
pickle Ric in one episode of Rick and
Morty so we actually haven't even
scratched the surface in everything that
he's capable of now getting into his
origin pickle Rick came into existence
at episode 3 of season 3 and the way
that he came into being is actually
pretty complicated in the sense that
Rick Sanchez turned himself into a
pickle now as far as how he turned
himself into a pickle that is not
explicitly stated in the episode which
is almost certainly due to the fact that
our minds would not be able to
comprehend the process by which the
transformation occurred what we can't
explain though is that Rick chose to do
this to himself while Rick's family
speculated that it was all a ploy to get
out of going to family therapy
Rick rebukes this notion and says that
his motivation for turning himself into
a pickle was quite simply to prove that
he could and goes on to say that no one
else would be capable of replicating
this feat so just based on that
statement alone we can move pickle Rick
into the omega-level category and the
logic supporting this is quite simple
Superman is clearly an omega-level
character Franklin Richards is clearly
an omega-level character all these
different characters are omega-level but
none of them have been able to turn
themselves into a pickle so just by the
very fact of pickle Rick's existence we
know that he's done something no one
else has been able to do now with his
origin out of the way we can now move on
to pickle Rick's set of powers and while
they are quite varied I think the best
way to sum it up is to simply say that
pickle Rick has all the abilities of a
super genius level pickle he's crunchy
he has a potent dill flavor and can
perfectly complement a variety of
entrees like hamburger Chicago style hot
dogs and pastrami sandwiches he also has
a genius-level intellect and because of
that intellect he's able to overcome all
the weaknesses that are inherent to
being a pickle namely being unable to
move of his own power and drying out if
exposed to air or sunlight so with all
that in mind let's get into the feats
that we've seen pickle Rick performed so
that we can get an idea of just how
powerful he is so after being knocked
into a sewer by rogue cat pickle Rick
uses his ability to secrete the salty
brine that runs through his pickle veins
into the ground beside him and lure a
cockroach over to him once the cockroach
is close enough to pickle Rick kills the
roach by biting down on its head
and then applies pressure to the dead
roaches brain to cause its corpse to
move and uses it as a rudimentary mode
of transport the next time we see pickle
Ric he's constructed a mech suit of
sorts out of the body parts of other
dead cockroaches that he's killed we
also learned that Ric has rigged a booby
trap that kills sewer rats and devises
an automated assembly line to use their
carcasses to create a more powerful mech
suit complete with a variety of weapons
and a jet pack now if you thought
building a suit of armor in a cave with
a box of scraps was impressive consider
how much harder it would be to build one
in a sewer out of a pile of rats so with
this feat alone we can surmise that
pickle Rick's intellect and ingenuity
are at least on par with those of Tony
Stark one of the smartest characters in
the Marvel Universe and are probably
even more advanced now following this
pickle Rick makes his way from the sewer
to the Russian embassy where he takes
down numerous Russian operatives through
his expertise as a battle strategist and
tactician now during this encounter we
see pickle Rick built a stick booby trap
out of pencils various explosives and a
battery-powered laser cannon capable of
disintegrating a human's head we also
learned that in the short time that
pickle rick has been mobile he's already
mastered the art of parkour making him a
much more formidable fighter now all in
all pickle Rick kills 35 highly trained
operatives in the embassy and his
devastation causes some of them to
believe that pickle rick is a figure
from russian folklore named Selenia that
rises from cold bowls of soup to steal
the souls of wasteful children now there
are probably some of you out there who
were saying like big deal be killed 35
Russian scientists Wolverine could do
that and he's not even considered
omega-level well sure you are right but
has Wolverine ever done that while he
was a pickle with that being said guys
if you enjoyed this and you want to see
the more comedic version then uh yeah go
ahead and and just kind of continue on
but if you don't and you are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you later please show me
what you got
yes all right let's then let us quiet on
the set all right Gordon I'm talking to
people in the discord Gordon is my
editor so when he hears me talking to
people that's that's what's going on
okay
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our video for omega beyond
omega level characters we're gonna do
something a little bit different
normally we stick with like comic book
characters right and technically
speaking this guy is a comic book
character but normally we stick to like
super heroes villains whatever and we
try to keep it kind of serious but every
once in a while you have to goof off so
in this video we are going to be making
a Omega Beyond Omega level video about
pickle rig I've tried to record this
five times I have not been able to keep
a straight face fingers crossed
wish me the best hopefully we get
through it one piece now if you're not
familiar with pickle rick he's a version
of rick sanchez from the animated series
rick and morty that airs on Cartoon
Network's Adult Swim and also has
produced its own comic book series from
Oni Press and while Rick in his standard
form boasts an impressive list of feats
pickle Rick simply takes him to another
level if it helps to understand this
concept in comic book terms think of
Rick Sanchez as the baseline version of
The Incredible Hulk and pickle Rick as
world breaker Hulk I really want to read
a story where row breaker Hulk fights
pickle Rick that really needs it
that really needs to happen but with
that being said if we're going to
understand the immense power that is
pickle Rick we first have to lay some
groundwork and explain who Rick Sanchez
is and what he's capable of I'm already
starting to laugh so Rick Sanchez is the
smartest man on earth and I'm not
exaggerating that as a scientist with a
superhuman intellect Rick has invented
numerous things that are far beyond what
was previously thought humanly possible
his most notable invention is his portal
gun which as the name implies allows him
to create portals to any point in space
in time in any universe and dream in
scepters which allow him to enter the
dreams of another person and implant new
thoughts into their minds much like the
movie exception damn it much like the
movie Inception except that these makes
sense quit laughing so at his base level
Rick can pretty much invent whatever he
needs to allow him to complete whatever
task he may overcome
so at his face level Rick and pretty
much invent whatever God it's not
laughing guys so at his base level Rick
can pretty much invent whatever he needs
to allow him to complete whatever task
or overcome whatever obstacle gets in
his way but we haven't even touched on
what pickle rick is capable of so i
think the best way to help you
understand pickle rick is to begin by
quickly going over his origin and then
discussing the feats that we've seen him
performed but getting into his origin
and pickle rick came into existence in
season three of pickle rick came into
existence of episode 3 in season 3 and
the way he came into existence is
actually really complicated so what
happened was that rick sanchez turned
himself into a pickle now as far as how
he turned himself into a pickle that's
not really stated in the episode which
is almost certainly due to the fact that
our minds wouldn't be able to comprehend
the process by which the transformation
occurred what we can't explain though is
why rick chose to do this to himself
while members of Rick's family
speculated that it was all employed what
am i what am i recording right now while
members of Rick's family speculated that
it was all a ploy to get out of going to
a family therapy session Rick himself
rebukes that notion and says that his
motivation for turning himself into a
pickle was quite simply to prove that he
could and goes on to say that no one
else would be capable of replicating
this feat so just based on that
statement alone we can move pickle Rick
into the ocean so just on that statement
alone we can move pickle Rick into the
omega-level category and the logic and
the logic supporting that is quite
simple
[Music]
this is the greatest logic in the
history of comic book might writer Ryan
wrote this script alright don't blame me
because I can't get through it without
keeping a straight face
Superman is clearly oh man Superman is
clearly omega-level right but he's never
been able to turn himself into a pickle
so just by the so just by the very fact
of pickle risk so so just by the very
fact of pickle Rick's existence we know
he's done something no one else has ever
been able to do now with his origin out
of the way we can move on to pickle
Rick's powers and while they are quite
varied I think the best way to sum this
up is simply to say that pickle rick has
all the abilities of a super juicer I
think the best way we can I think the
best way we can sum this up is simply
simply to say that pickle rick has all
the abilities of a super ginger of a
super genius level pickle I swear to god
guys I'm really trying to keep a
straight face of this pickle Rick pickle
Rick it's crunchy alright we gotta we
gotta get through this we got to get
through this we got to get through this
alright pickle rick is crunchy he has a
potent dill flavor and can perfectly
compliment a variety of entrees like
hamburgers Chicago style hot dogs and
pastrami sandwiches he also has a
genius-level intellect and because of
that intellect he's able to overcome all
the weaknesses that are inherent to
being a pickle namely and because and
because of that intellect he's able to
overcome all the weaknesses that are
inherent to being a pickle namely
being unable to move under his own power
and drying out if exposed to air or
sunlight now with all that in mind let's
get into let's get into the feats that
we've seen pickle Ric perform so that we
can get an idea of just how powerful he
is this is the most ridiculous thing
I've ever done so after being knocked
into a sewer by Road cabbage pickle Ric
uses his ability to secrete pickle Ric
uses his ability just to create the
salty brine that runs through his
pickled veins onto the ground beside him
to a pickle Ric uses his ability to
secrete the salty brine that runs
through his pickled veins into onto the
ground beside him to lure a passing
cockroach over to him once the cockroach
is close enough pickle Rick kills the
cockroach by biting down on its head and
then applies pressure to the dead
cockroaches brain to cause its corpse to
move and uses it as a whoop and uses it
as a rudimentary mode of transport when
we next see pickle Ric he's constructed
a mech suit of sorts out of body parts
of other cockroaches that he's killed we
also learned that Ric has triggered a
booby trap that kills sewer rats and
devises an automated assembly line to to
use their carcasses to create a more
powerful mech suit complete with a
variety of weapons and a jet pack now if
you thought building a suit of armor in
a cave with a box of scraps was
impressive consider how much harder it
is to build one in a sewer out of a pile
of rats so with this feat alone we can
surmise that pickle Rick's intellect and
ingenuity are at least on par with those
of Tony Stark one of the smartest
characters in the Marvel Universe
and are probably even more advanced
Robert Downey jr. eat your heart out man
you got nothing on pickle Ric now
following this pickle Ric makes his way
from the sewer to the Russian embassy
during this encounter we see pickle Ric
build a punji during this during this
encounter we see pickle Ric built a
punji stick booby trap out of pencils
various explosives and a battery power
laser cannon capable of disintegrating a
human's head we also learned that in the
short time that picker Ric has been
mobile he's already mastered the art of
parkour making him a far more formidable
fighter all-in-all piggle Rick kills
thirty five highly trained operatives in
a Russian embassy and his devastation
causes some of them to believe pickle
Rick to be a and its devastation causes
some of them to believe that pickle Ric
is a figure from from Russian folklore
named Selenia that rises from cold bowls
of soup to steal the souls of wasteful
children but he isn't he's simply a
super-smart type he's simply a
super-smart scientist it turned himself
into a pickle now some of you out there
are probably saying big deal Rob
he killed 35 Russian agents Wolverine
could do that and he's not even
considered to be a wreck a level sure
[Music]
well sure Wolverine could kill 35 you
are correct you are absolutely correct
Wolverine has killed 35 Russian agents
presumably at some point in his
publication history and if he hasn't
then he probably could but he's never
done it as a pickle at least not
according to any stories that I could
find and until he does then argument is
that argument isn't valid as far as I'm
concerned so anyway guys that's pretty
much everything we have about pickle
Rick uh he is clearly an Omega beyond
Omega level character one of the most
powerful characters to ever exist in the
history of comic books uh without being
said guys wouldn't go ahead and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you somehow made it through to
the end of this video make sure you drop
a like and yeah I will catch you all
later face
[Music]